all right Mom
literally I have heard it literally
whatever because this is the last time
you invited to one of our dinners
because clearly yeah your mind's not off
yeah you don't know how to spend your
money and I'm sick of it
[Music]
what's good guys what's good girls your
back is sng episode 221 yes that's where
we're at now
it's like the best podcast in the world
221 like we're just we're just out we're
doing numbers we're doing good bits
literally doing bits literally doing
bits um and by the time this episode
drops
our live show will be a few days away no
facts I love shows on Thursday yeah
Shepherd's Bush Empire you might be
thinking Lads that's a big venue isn't
it yeah it is just a bit but we're big
boys we are big boys we're big in the
game you know
um
you want to roll with the big boys as
they say here we are you're rolling with
us yeah bro yeah you wanna run with the
big boys you got to do big boy [ __ ] so
anyway guys looking forward to every
single person that's coming out uh to
see us on Thursday we hope we can
deliver the best show you've ever seen
um and if not then it's too late
literally no refunds
um but anyway guys before we jump into
it what we need to do first is tell you
to pause the episode right here head on
over to patreon.com
shits and gigs to get three years worth
of bonus episodes guys three years worth
of bundles episodes as well as an
episode every single Thursday as well as
discount on our merch facts as well as
invites to our monthly Zoom chat excuse
me Zoom chat as well as
juicy continuous conversations that head
on over on our new Discord server it's
only been open a few days and I'm not
gonna lie guys the patrons get down over
there they talk they talk there's been
filthy filthy chat I'm not gonna lie
when it first set up the first few
hundred people that were in there they
went into the chops and thread I'm just
gonna throw out there it was a sausage
fest yeah
it was a sausage okay it was just hungry
breast yeah just
wait a minute we're just trapsing up
where's the [ __ ] Center where the sweet
one mom I clicked and I was like yuck
clicked off we're gonna have to spice
this up yeah by the time I came back a
couple days later
Tit for Tat tip for Tat tip for tap we
were rallying over there so I was like
oh Jesus so I'm actually terrified for
when these might meet up in person in
the life I'm scared to see what's gonna
happen that man are gonna be ancestral
yeah
um but obviously guys
heading over to patreon it's three pound
a month Tempe a day run the pizza sng
and join the cult babies for Life cult
babies for Life guys
um as well guys if you are watching us
on YouTube thank you so much and please
like the video if you like the video
comment chirps a thing in there
subscribe to the channel and leave the
notifications on because your boys post
hot and fast now we post all the times
all the time it's it we can't be
bothered to remind you every single time
so notifications on I've got the
itchiest notes if you're wondering why
don't you touch his nose no I haven't
just done a lie a line of cochain I've
just got the itchy's nose I don't know
why
um also guys if you listen to the audio
on any app any app whether it's Spotify
Apple podcast Amazon music audible
whatever you listen to please please
please please leave us a nice review and
a healthy star rating five is preferable
perfect say what you want to say okay as
long as you're true to yourself we
appreciate it okay so please do that and
it helps us spread the word to everyone
out there it helps the cult grow and it
helps
our pockets at the end of the day and
that's what it's really all about
literally is only about our pockets and
that's what it helps so that's why we
started we started this whole thing
because she took everything and we need
it back you started this because she
took everything and we want to run it
back literally she took everything and
we need Pockets back we needed a reason
to have pockets because there was
nothing going on in there yeah and now
there's a little something going on
there but not quite enough yeah so guys
please
tell a friend to tell a friend to tell a
friend and please let's have fun every
single week okay
um and without any further Ado my
boyfriends wants to talk about the sport
he loves he wants to share some facts
and talk about the sport he loves guys
and buckle up five love ways is going to
spit some uh some lava at you yeah man
um so in the world of football recently
there's been sort of fun fact is a
couple football scandals
scandals bro um so you know do you know
who Benjamin Mendy is yeah actually yeah
so you know you know do you know what's
going on in and around him
so he's uh for those that don't know
Benjamin Mandy is a I think he's a left
back actually he's a left back that
plays or played still plays played for
man city
um he got charged for rape oh of course
yeah he dodged the ticket the last time
he played was August 2021. oh that's the
last time he touched
2021 was the last time he played um so
Benjamin declared of one count of rape
against the 19 year old woman
Man City Star Ben Mendy was today
cleared of one count of rape and his
alleged fixer of three other sex charges
after a tape of one of their encounters
was revealed in court his co-defendant
and friend Louis Sahar maturi was also
cleared of two counts of rape and one of
sexual assaults both against the same
woman Christ
Christ's Scandal well I and you they
ducked it they've ducked this first [ __ ]
but there's other counts there's other
um there's other
women that have come forward without
saying that because it's not just one
woman so yeah it's long this one is he's
he's bus case for this one but I think
there's like two or three other more all
right so right for him um and on the
other side uh Mason Greenwood so do you
hear about the one I miss agreement and
um this was I think I think this was
this year or was it last year
um where you beat up his Missus and it
was recorded it was all over socials I
think it was this year earlier this year
it must have been earlier this year did
I see that anyway Mason Greenwood
remains on Manchester United's squad
list amidst suspension so masonry with
20 year old man united forward who was
suspended following accusations of
sexual assault and threat to murder is
included on in the official man united
Squad of 2022-2023
the former England player has been
included on the club's list under 21's
player eligible to feature in a Premier
League game this season however this
does not signal a change in his
circumstances to be to being in the
squad so yeah he um
he him and his girlfriend at the time
they got into an altercation and
I think she recorded him it was what
remember when um
when we were doing when we did the three
shots of tequila and
um Keith was talking about the Hulk
Hogan situation yeah sorry I do yeah
yeah
now I'm
today yeah
yeah my man he was she recorded him and
obviously apparently you can't
it's inadmissible kind of things
inadmissible yeah permission to do it
that's the reason why he quote unquote
bust that case or maybe that's the
reason why he's legally allowed to be
put in the squad because I haven't seen
the video though well oh this was time
ago no yeah the video you don't see him
actually doing anything to him but she
shows pictures of like cuts and bruises
and blood and things like that and
there's there's audio so there's a lot
of voice notes there's a lot of audio of
them arguing back and forth arguing back
and forth and she says stop and he says
sign like no
yeah yeah yeah I don't know won't me
yeah she says stop
so one one is um
one Scandal is the Man City scandal with
Benjamin Mendy uh another Scandal is uh
with uh Mason Greenwood and man united
and it's just it's just crazy because
it's one of those ones where
if you remove
if we remove
them from the footballing world
it wouldn't if I've even gotten this far
like they would have been behind bars oh
right yeah let's let's be real let's be
honest yeah there was no if they had no
um what's the word I'm looking for any
power in the football in wild world if
they had any like movement or any motion
like they would have been either locked
up or whichever job they're in they
would have been done and dust in time
yeah wrapped up time ago it just goes to
show like even though a lot of
um
people in positions of power
like to take the piss they can still
they can still be brought back to
reality because Mason green for example
he's 20. I don't know how old uh Mendes
he can't be past 25 like these are these
are young last boys you know what I mean
and it's like the amount of exposure and
money and women thrown at you and the
lifestyle and all these accessible free
things I'd like it corrupts them like
the rings of power right oh corrupts oh
it's like crazy I can't imagine having
that now at
31.20 20 bro we were doing nonsense yeah
yeah 20. I mean yeah we weren't putting
pause on hoes yeah yeah we we we we're
doing foolishness yeah so it's like
having that
millions in your aliens and the pressure
and fame the pressure in the city in
Manchester as well yeah that's the Hub
yeah if you're a bowler in Manchester is
this yeah it's it's fun it's it's part
but your life is like you have it's so
annoying how
well not annoying because I have no idea
but I just feel like it would be
annoying because they have no sense of
Freedom apart from one when they're on
the pitch and probably when they're with
their boys or whatever or going out once
in a blue moon because there is there is
no especially when you're young in this
in well the footballer world or fame
world or whatever
you have to still have a sense of
decorum everywhere else you go apart
from where you're meant to be I.E like a
football pitch basketball pitch yeah
you're an actor or whatever I always
wonder though when these accusations
come out like domestic abuse is a
different thing like a software is a
different thing because that's just like
that's just you yeah like you're just
that guy yeah yeah yeah but when it
comes to like the rape stuff I guess
obviously you could be that guy in class
because I don't I don't know I don't
know too much about like the psychology
of that but like in terms of like we
actually said like you're that famous
you're that rich and you definitely get
yeah like
where are these at what why are you just
out here doing this like literally why
like obviously there's the side of it
like oh man there's so much pressure
there's so much this there's so much
everything I'm only 20 like my brain's
not even developed yet et cetera etc etc
but same time it's like
what I what what are you looking for
that you're not getting in facts what
are you looking for are you not getting
that you're just like committing the
most heinous of crimes bro like and
multiple chicks are coming forward and
being like big man yes he did
he dates
listen to me if I'm in court and a bus
case for one
and I'm seeing I'm hearing mermaids out
the door I'm saying keep him on Stan
because listen brav that will scare the
Chrysler as it should as it should facts
yes as it should ax yeah you could ever
if I was there as your Confidant and I'm
in I'm in The Stance yeah and I see you
bus case and I'm like all right all
right and you tell me if you told me bro
I did not do it yeah I did not do it
yeah and I'm like all right man yeah I
know you I know you yeah all right say
less and I'm in there I'm listening to
the the jury and everything and then you
bus case and I'm like say less that's my
guy and I look over here and there's a
queue of chicks and they're all your
time
they're all your type and I look and I
think
I wouldn't even get to the back I would
get like the third one in oh he [ __ ]
did it
they [ __ ] did it stand up I'm like
bro why are you lying for me
I'd see you like glaze over the crowd
like make contact with me and look away
all right this [ __ ] did it this
one put him away
you hit me come to my mouth
why yeah well why you have everything
why
I have everything I wanted it yeah
apparently you wanted everything I
wanted everything you were you yeah you
weren't interested in civil conversation
anymore you were saying run me skins
I I'm I'm a bowler I'm a bowler run me
skin now wait for United yeah like
literally
what else should I say yeah I play for
United
bro yes
I don't really yeah it's a weird one
because there is no like
how to explain it
there really is no kind of
process in which the game is rigged
because like you give like I said you
give all these guys all this money all
this Fame all this power and like
under normal circumstances if you're
just any Brea if you're just any estate
agent um
like
you're going to be vetted by these girls
before you even get in a situation like
that but because the com because they're
so aware that the competition the
competition to get to you is so high
they're willing to hop skip and jump or
this vet in process you could be a
serial killer that they'll they they're
not gonna fight out until it's too late
too late yeah because they know there's
bearings trying to run through your yard
so if they get an invite they're going
they're going well if you're like I said
if you're any estate agent and you're
like come around like why yeah why are
you mad like what fox yeah you sound
like a cereal yeah relax you're only a
estate agent yes silly stay in your lane
stay in your [ __ ] Financial life yeah
I want you
and then yeah you you rolled a baller
and then this is how we end up in court
because some of these guys are [ __ ]
um it's a it's a tougher one I don't
there's not really a there's never going
to be like a
a cure for it because it's self
perpetuating yeah like the girls aren't
gonna stop
jumping into bed with these Amanda
which means the bad apples are just
gonna continue to do what they do until
it's too late and they've done what
they've done and even though they go pen
it still doesn't prevent the next the
process the next process yeah yeah yeah
you just the one brother does it yeah he
gets caught
ghost pen but then the girls don't think
oh [ __ ]
this kind of [ __ ] is what
gets gets gets you touched up oh there
was a there was a I think his name is
Adam Johnson I could be wrong I think he
used to play for like Southampton or
something he got done for like touching
Utes and stuff he's been in pen since
like 2011.
Christopher Adam Johnson I could be
wrong Adam Johnson English footballer
used to play for City
as well
um
yeah sexual assault with a minor six
years in prison yeah yeah Christ yeah
yeah nuts bro that's the thing as well I
was
like
playing football is a skill it has no
there are no kind of like redeeming
qualities in your personality that you
need to have to be good at football you
just need to be good at football so
whatever goes on in your head yeah yeah
is a different Beast yeah it's a wild
one bro um but anyways
continuing from that just the good stuff
now yeah all right that was the that was
that was the dog
um that's the good side of football so
yeah it was Champions League where by
the time this comes out two weeks ago
but I was watching Champions League um
last week so yeah Champions League chat
um so Barcelona
um played um Bayern Munich or Bayern
versus Barcelona by me and we're at home
and for those I don't know those are two
really good prolific teams uh Bayern won
their season they've been winning their
seat um their league
umpteen times PSG have won their league
on teen times and they're both won their
respective leagues last season
and Bayern and Barca did I just say PhD
by the way you said PSG yeah sorry basa
won their no boss it didn't win their
season last year I think Real Madrid won
the season last season but they're a
prolific teams yeah everyone knows
they're Barcelona so yeah so
um but Bayern and boss have played
before in the Champions League and buy
and tucked bars are in eight two
maybe two three years ago maybe three
years ago eight two yeah yeah it was a
game in the Champions League yes bro
exactly exactly yeah buying or a good
team yeah you know what I mean so yeah
but anyway
and obviously every season there's
always reshuffles people buy and sell
players and blah blah blah so there is a
player called
um Leroy Sani who used to play for Man
City who now plays for Bayern Munich but
he's been in buyer for like three two or
three seasons
um and sadio Mane who used to play for
Liverpool now plays for Bayern Munich
he's now their Striker and I always used
to get money and sign his name confused
and now they play for the same [ __ ]
team but yeah
um they the the game itself was
fantastic because we both I say we both
we all knew that game was going to be a
good game because Bayern Munich versus
Barcelona and to add more salt into it
um Bayern Munich's old prolific Strife
car was Robert Lewandowski who has now
left and gone to Barcelona
so Leroy Sani Lucy I did again sadio
Mane replaced Lewandowski
juicy yeah so he's come back to his old
stomping ground with basa in an away
game to try and see if you can you know
pattern sign yeah he had two really
really good chances in the first half
bold it
absolutely the pressure was too much
yeah the pressure like the thing is
there were good passes I feel like if it
was Lewandowski or Bayern Munich he
would have buried both of them and the
pressure maybe was just too much for him
knowing that psychologically this isn't
my yard anymore
and he bottled it
um but bastard scored two so Buster
scored two in the second half um Bayern
scored two in the second half so he said
okay Barcelona lost two nil
but going off from that
um
earling Harland who now plays for City
used to play in Germany used to play for
Bruce your Dortmund
coincidentally the next day because they
do champions league on Tuesdays and
Wednesday so coincidentally on the
Wednesday
the draw was Bayern Munich versus by um
Borussia Dortmund sorry versus Man City
so early Harlem again his old team yeah
City one three note and hurland scored
so Harland
he stood up to the challenge he stood up
to the challenge and he he did very very
[ __ ] well which is annoying because
he scored like I think 12 goals in 11
games or something like that is he's
taken that he scored two back-to-back
hat tricks a few weeks ago he stayed
he's on my Tick Tock yeah he stays he's
uh people suck him off taking the piss
is what he's doing he's a he's actually
a beast of a striker it's unbearable
yeah it's actually unbearable it's
undeniable as well regardless of however
you whoever you support and however you
want to depict football and try and
break it down into his components erling
Harlot is a [ __ ] Striker and it
frustrates
and you know the maddest thing so um
prior to my or post my last like rant
slash talk about United
um I predicted that we were gonna
win against
um our Europa League game and
um be a tight game against Crystal
Palace I think I don't know how many of
you I do remember we lost our Europa
League game one nil when I was vexed
about that yeah and our Crystal Palace
game got postponed and then we had a um
another Europa League game against I
can't remember what they call it Sheriff
the teams are currently where they're
from though
um
but we won that game too now and then
our other game our other Premier League
game got postponed again because of the
whole Queen situation yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so we've not played two
Premier League games on our next game is
October the second and it's against City
and it's away and it's like
I would have loved to have played or I
would have loved for our team to have
played those two Premier League games
and actually potentially win them to
gain momentum and have you know the
mentality of okay cities next we've just
come off two wins we should be good you
know obviously yes we won a Europa
League game but the two different
competitions you know the last Premier
League game we played we did win but it
was weeks ago yeah yeah weeks ago so
it's going to be a probably a month
since we played oh that's not on or like
three weeks maybe four three yeah three
to four weeks between our Premier League
it's not so warm you know what I mean we
need to say fluids yeah City next it's
like or playing away with Harlan doing
yeah and Kevin deploy are doing what
he's doing you know them and a ball is
up yeah I hate to say it but they're
boilers yeah you know it's gonna be a
tough game but we've also got a strong
unit so I'm looking I'm very much
looking forward to that game
um I'm gonna say it now my prediction
for that game is going to either be
a draw 2-2
or free to United
three to United yes and that's it yeah
all right yeah all right I'm just I'm
asking prediction because the thing is
right sounds like a wish
but yeah go on the thing is right
we've not I said I was gonna say we've
not beat City in a while but I think we
beat City not last season maybe two
seasons ago beat them three times in
we played them four times we beat them
three times
um but they've always played better than
us like in the past I'd say Five Seasons
we've probably won about two or three
games bro yeah and it's just not been
good it's not been good yes they are
much better than they were last season
and we are much better than we were last
season but we're not there but I still
feel like the game against Liverpool we
we brought it all the game against
arsenal we brought it all but again
those games were both home games so we
will see we will see I'm hoping I'm
hoping good luck my god I've been um
United do the business
um and if they don't I guess they
[ __ ] don't in it I'm just gonna be
living you're gonna hear another rap
[ __ ] so yeah right right next up it's
been a few weeks we've got try not to
laugh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah so this
time we're gonna go back to back you go
when you go how many have I got I've got
one two three four five I've got six six
okay I've got five you go first all
right cool I'll go first okay so I've
got a couple dark humans a couple listen
let me grab a drink right
try not to laugh yeah back to back
right
I just
why can't I even say it bro I don't know
bro I'm so funny sometimes your laugh
makes me laugh no no no that's
frustrated I'm sorry I'll try not to I
just read that someone in London gets
stabbed every 52 seconds
poor guy
oh my God
that one was funny to me when I read it
that's when that's what that's what I
was laughing at when I was trying to get
them okay that made me giggle all right
you're up
no means no
unless she's dyslexic then it's on
cool that's not hard
waiting for you to say that
oh right you've probably seen this one
actually I've seen this I ended up
seeing this one on like four or five
different websites so you've probably
seen it I'm not an L because you you
stay on these dark humor websites so
you've probably read all of them
all right
wife says I'm pregnant
husband hi pregnant I'm dad wife no
you're not
P can you imagine no I can't I'm
pregnant hi pregnant I'm dad hmm
nah big man this is not yours it's
actually you're actually not
you're not husband either oh God right
go life for that woman would be a pain
in the ass
took a second sunk in that's a good joke
I'm not gonna laugh that is a good joke
right
ready
[Music]
why
why is there air conditioning
why is there air conditioning in
hospitals
why is there air conditioning in
hospitals I don't know
to keep the vegetables cool and fresh oh
my God
oh wow
[Laughter]
oh bro that's dark cool cool and fresh
[ __ ]
how do parents punish a blind child
foreign
by rearranging the furniture
that's not even on
can you imagine
oh that'd be [ __ ] Savage can you
imagine does a blind
just struggling say Mom I thought I
mapped this terrain where am I where am
I that will be it wherever I woke up
that's exactly where I'll be saying
where the [ __ ] am I because this ain't
hard yeah whose yard is it I know I've
mapped out my yard in my head I know
where it's man I'm just sitting on sofa
silent
nah that's that's not [ __ ] on all
right
thought opening right I thought opening
a door for a lady was good manners but
she just screamed and flew out of the
plane
screamed and flew out of the plane
bro that's so stupid I read I was so
stupid
right got him there's a white boy a
Mexican boy and a black boy who are all
in the fifth grade
who has the biggest dick
I don't know bro the black boy because
he's 18.
[Laughter]
bro
nah that's funny as racist and funny
fifth grade bro bro that's so it's a
repeat offender that's so rude
all right hit me right
dad joke yeah yeah why did the man miss
the funeral
I don't know
he wasn't a morning person
all right all right my last one yeah
this brother was banging his sister and
he says you [ __ ] just like mum
and she laughs he says what she says
that's what Dad said
yuck
yuck
that's so disgusting
Jesus Christ
that makes me feel sick
oh [ __ ] that is grim
right last one yeah
I hope death is a woman
that way that way it will never come for
me oh wow self-deprecating
there you go try not to laugh I think
I lost obviously yeah you did but I did
I'm trying to think that I actually lose
at the I don't think I'll have to end oh
you try not to laugh at the on one
dyslexic one yeah
um
you laughed at because he's 18 but not
because of the joke right because it was
not too bad I did actually laugh for the
joke that's funny yeah okay I think you
won that one you were I think you left
at one of mine
um
no maybe you didn't
did you laugh out I'm pregnant no you're
not maybe you did I don't know I think I
did anyway I lost I was [ __ ] news
anyways there's literally no point
um
okay cool
next up we have um i z [ __ ]
okay so let's give it a read this one I
liked because it wasn't super long
imagine she said that to you
I actually like your dick because it's
not super long yeah all the rest the big
ones hurt that one that one she started
off with the saying I already know the
answer to this but I need you to
reinforce me so let's go
would I be the [ __ ] if I reached out
to an ex who left me to get married to
his girlfriend who just had his baby
would I repeat that sentence again I
knew I would be would I be the [ __ ]
if I reached out to my ex who left me to
get married
who um who who left me to get married
with his girl who's just had his baby
wow okay right backstory
a year ago I picked up a hitchhiker from
the side of the road as it was raining
and I offered him a ride to the gas
station he got in and had a French
accent I asked him where he's from and
he said France
foreign
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
that's right
um he said France but he's in the states
to play professional soccer okay I ended
up giving him a ride to his car and he
gave me his number and said that he owes
me one offered me tickets to his next
game
I immediately looked him up because I
obviously thought it was a homeless guy
trying to bang
why would that be the immediate thought
my immediate thought is this hitchhike
as a homeless guy trying to [ __ ] that's
hilarious turns out he used to play for
Monaco
over the neck over the next uh over the
next five months we spent every day
together and had mad chemistries it is
excessive wow zero to a hundred he met
my parents my friends and all my
co-workers one day I called him
um and he said he's he's on his way to
the airport
excuse me plus I have my throat [ __ ]
one day I called him and he said he's on
his way to the airport as his girlfriend
as his girlfriend just gave birth to
their son
he's going to Mario while he's gone and
he'll but he'll be here in one week he
left me the key to his apartment and
left
of course I was shocked
um and didn't get my words out of course
I was shot by all of this and didn't
contact him at all a couple weeks after
a couple weeks after his newlywed his
new wife oh [ __ ] hell I can't read
today a couple weeks after his newly
married wife reached out to me and said
her husband won't stop talking about me
what's going on
so I tell her everything anyway a year
now a year now has gone
[ __ ] the way they they typed this is
hard to read anyway a year now has gone
by they're still happily married raising
their kid but I miss him so much I
haven't found a connection with anything
anyone like that in my life would I be
the [ __ ] if I reached out to him and
told him I miss him 100. without a
shadow of a doubt yeah literally because
darling listen you so his wife five
months after like were giving birth or
whatever the marriage or whatever
said
yo there's you're a chick that my
husband can't stop talking about tell me
wagwan you told her everything and they
still stay together for another year bro
you're she clearly got mad and got over
it literally so there is no I don't know
what fantasy you've got in your head
that you think you can holler him and
he'll be like oh [ __ ] yeah let's go like
because that's never gonna happen to be
fair I actually disagree because homeboy
sounds like a sociopath why why not yeah
yeah right let me put this down
foreign
he sounds like a sociopath to me
because
she met him
they spent every day together and then
out of the blue he said FYI I'm going
back to France because my girl who you
don't know about is pregnant and she's
about to have my baby
I'm also going to marry her while I'm
over there as well but I'll be back in a
week here's my key do your thing I'll
see you in a week he said the
haphazardly
then continue they got married yeah she
hasn't spoke to him in a year
but he's telling his wife all about this
hoe in America
non-stop yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
what are you doing my guy he's a he's a
narcissist he's a narcissist he's a
narcissist so I wouldn't be surprised if
she messaged him and said I miss you
he'll be like all right I miss you too I
miss you too now that you've said it
like that and painted it in that like
100 agree because as going back to
[ __ ] up sorry guys going back to what
we said in the literally beginning of
the episode footballers clearly want to
do what they want yeah you know what I
mean they don't give a [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] about social construct or
anything yeah they do what they want God
complex so facts God complex so it's
like
the fact that he casually told you
I'm dipping back to France my wife my
wife's pregnant or my wife to be his
pregnant I'm gonna marry her but here is
my key I'll be back
I wouldn't know how to risk I wouldn't
know how to digest that information if a
girl told me that oh
we've been together for five months
every day we've got a connection and
then one day I'm like where you at so
I'm just on the way to airport oh swear
where are you going where the [ __ ] are
you going you got an away game I like
nah I'm gonna go get married
fall to my niece
my fiance and my son are waiting for me
I'm gonna go see them I'm gonna get
married but I'll be back in a week
here's mine I've left the key under the
mat
stay enjoy yourself I'm back in a week
I'd probably rate the balls on her to be
fair oh
my life is literally a dream my life
that's a joke yeah my life is a joke
because the last five months I've been
planning [ __ ] oh we're together together
I thought we were on this phone she
thought she literally had a footballer
boyfriend
she literally was like looking for
houses and stuff they've been together
every day every day for half a year
months
yo that's yeah you're on my man is a
narcissist so
are you the [ __ ] for wanting to
message to say she misses him yeah she
misses him and she wants to message him
it's been a year he's married and has a
child and you've decided I don't care
yeah which is fine yeah yeah you are an
[ __ ] yeah it's fine sometimes it is
fine to be the [ __ ] but yeah you
decide I don't care I just care about me
um
I'm tired of not caring about me so I'm
gonna tell him I miss him so he can come
back and keep [ __ ] me
wow because I haven't found that
connection again since five months every
day
and he's got a wife and potential you
back home and she said I don't care
about that that's all Chit Chat come and
connect with man come with your network
man because this man over here just not
doing they're just not doing it I need
that that francaise you
know you're providing it yeah
and you've got a level of bravado I
didn't think was possible didn't even
conceive of such a thing you told me to
my face I've got a wife I'll be back in
a week leave me alone I still want you
and I want I want you back I don't know
what's wrong with me but I know there's
everything wrong with you and I want to
be yeah I want to be a part of that
a simple happy life because she told us
she's definitely painting herself that
same picture that so many girls do that
like he must love me because he cheated
on his fiance with me he's pregnant
fiance he must love me he spent every
day with me he must love me and I love
him so I'm gonna message him I mean you
could love him but he he doesn't love he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about you and he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about his wife he's
just himself through his life because
the whole thing he said I'm caked shut
the [ __ ] up it doesn't matter it
literally doesn't matter because the
worst thing you've got to turn around
and say you're leaving me goodbye it's
going to be other things other things
other opportunities I will still pay for
my you and I'll still see my you when I
want to see my yeah yeah you're
irrelevant yeah
is not narcissistic bro that's crazy but
yeah it doesn't matter because you've
got to message him anyway because you
already knew you were to [ __ ] before
you sent the message but you still sent
the message you're gonna hear this back
and go well you're gonna probably record
it yeah and send it to my man and look
at these words us
this is so us
reconnecting bang is going to be next
level and it's just gonna validate every
every wrong decision you make yes it's
gonna be validated after that one
because he's got a nut oh right he's
gonna not in dip bro he's good on that
and his missus will FaceTime him while
he's still ass naked yeah Landon on his
dick what are you up to yeah do you just
speak in French to her until he told you
to shut the [ __ ] up I'm speaking to my
wife
know your place know your [ __ ] and
you're gonna love it yeah you're gonna
love it
so the covers iron [ __ ] sake hurry up
hurry the [ __ ] up hurry the [ __ ] up
because I want it again yeah hurry up
hurry up and this is how this is how
football is just yeah
famous people get away with [ __ ] Rags
they give them the license and they just
take oh yeah Rags because he shows you
sweet life for five months and then it
doesn't matter what happens after that
because you're just clinging onto it
it's like literally the what we spoke
about I think it was last week
um
the
um is it the millionaire one where she
acclimatized to this Rich lifestyle and
yeah yeah as soon as you go broke again
yeah yeah I want reparations for this
yeah one half like what's going on Ben
broke for 24 years yeah yeah 100 100
acclimatized man but yeah um I thought I
was [ __ ] jokes um you are the [ __ ]
or you will be an ass if you message him
yeah
100 she has right I want to talk to you
about the skeptical yeah the skeptic
thing um so for those who have not seen
skepta has
um a painter called Mama goes to Market
um it's gonna be the briefs of uh rapper
skeptic is making his debut into the art
world with his painting Mama goes to
market the patent will be on public
exhibition in Sotheby's New Body Street
galleries before his auction skepta said
I live and breathe art in everything I
do everything I think
um for the audio listeners it's
basically just a picture of
um three moms going to work in somewhere
in Africa presumably Nigeria considering
is Nigerian and they were like African
attire and they're just like selling
things on roads and one of the mums has
got carry the U on her back and it's
just in like a the background shows
like graffiti and stuff and it's
definitely Nigeria because I can tell by
like the the yellow bus and like the
palm trees and stuff oh okay that's what
it looks like yeah so the reason why to
be fair the reason why I did want to
speak about this is because do you know
how much you got sold for oh is it going
to auction yeah so it was estimated
auction between 40 and 60 bags
the weird thing this is the weird thing
this is his first is this his first
painting to my knowledge to my knowledge
this is his first this is yeah I'm sure
it says debut yeah I think it it is yeah
making his debut into the art World
painting yeah yeah right this is the
thing that confused about stuff like
this right so like
especially when you talk about art art
is only worth as much as someone is
willing to pay for it
so for a debut piece that hasn't yet
been sold
[Music]
how the [ __ ] can someone just be like 40
to 60 bags based on what yeah he's never
sold anything before because like art is
not necessarily about like technical
ability it's just about like the appeal
and what it connects to the people that
are going to buy it so like if you sell
a piece for a million quid your next
piece someone can evaluate it and be
like I can see this making two million I
can see this making half of it they have
a ballpark figure to go on based on the
fact that someone is willing to buy your
art for that much but like yeah if
you've never done anything before how
would someone be like oh it's worth 60
Grand literally I have no idea but a lot
surrounded a lot of people went to view
it um when it was in the exhibition and
guess how much it sold for take a guess
oh Raw just take a ride oh I I hope it
sold for 350 pounds but I'm probably
gonna
I'm probably gonna go for five bags
nearly 82 bags
it's sold for 81 900 900 pounds and it
was estimated between 40 and 60 bucks it
did it sold for 80 grand skepta's photo
bro this is the reason why I was talking
about it's like paint painting it's like
I've seen like that don't get me wrong I
understand the concept of the art
because one I'm Nigerian I understand
what he's talking about I understand the
title obviously
um
but it it's not an AET back paying
to be candid it's not an 82 back pain
yeah I've seen I've seen um oil
paintings on Twitter that look and I was
gonna say incredible and amazing at the
same time it looked [ __ ] amazing
[ __ ] amazing I'm thinking yeah bro
that should be 82 batch yeah because
what you just paid it doesn't make sense
bro the art world is a Fickle one
skepta but then also
who's that is shopping for skepta's art
unless I'm a die-hard skepta fan
I don't necessarily think it matters if
you're a die-hard skepta fan or not
because I've because I feel like it's so
left like skept as a rapper yeah you
know what I mean everyone knows skepta
from for his music and his production or
all of them things so because and
because he's not done music in I don't
think he's put our music this year I
think last time we played music was last
year if I recall
um or he's been on like features and
stuff
um he's
the fact that he's just gone into
obviously something he's probably taken
time to do that's the reason why he's
not really been doing much my assumption
um it's so left field and because it's
kept a skept is still a household London
England name
it's going to be like oh raw skepticated
so it's going to cause traction cause
all this traffic
that was obvious but it's like I don't
know I can't even think of an example I
was gonna say if maybe if skepta for
example
not even skepta let's say if um
I don't know
if one of us for example all of a sudden
started to
I don't know probably play football or
[ __ ] be be in uh go on MasterChef for
example it's so far left from what we do
yeah yeah it's like oh I'm intrigued
yeah yeah that's the thing as well but
that's a that's West where it gets me
was like I am intrigued but I'm I've
seen it now yeah yeah that my Intrigue
stops yeah I'm not paying it yeah you're
not getting my money yeah the Intrigue
stops there yeah yeah yeah oh that's my
80s 82 bags bro
I've seen artwork like oh working here
let alone oh yeah fun good shot
something fun good shots but I don't
know man that's a weird one I'm not oh
it's literally subjective and it's just
it's it's one of them things just like I
don't care enough either that to form
like to keep this argument go I just
don't care I literally do not care but
that's an outrageous amount of money to
sell your first piece of art but then
once but rich people stay Rich at the
end of the day facts like facts yeah he
was never going to be like a struggling
artist
um and he has so much money anyway he
could he could literally just send
someone in there he could just send a
couple couple like moles in there and be
like a bid for my [ __ ] please and then
just pay the eight bags up front so that
moving forward it's an 80 bags base yeah
80 bags is the base like 80 bags and
people who were in The Last auction were
thinking [ __ ] but I need to get my hands
on the next one yeah because he's sold
he's gonna come up he's sold yeah
stupid and also I could never have a
piece of art in my house if I've got if
I'm an art collector and I'm spending
hundreds of grams of art I could never
have someone say who's this piece by
I had dinner party and I'd be like
skepta be like who skepta BBK
don't ever say that again
you know BBK that's hilarious BK brother
of Jamie
um yeah nah that that could never pack
yeah that dinner table went down you
will hear Cutlery drop oh Rags what is
it little local pro bono little Charity
buy what was it nah I just liked it and
it was eight bags 80 bags for skepters
how many pieces he does this is the
first one
all right Mom
literally
literally whatever because this is the
last time you invited to one of our
dinners because clearly yeah your mind's
not off yeah you don't know how to spend
your money and I'm sick of it let's just
eat the [ __ ] food get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah that's right man
that was literally people response yeah
I can imagine going to your yard when
we're here when you when you start
spending your money on expensive [ __ ]
yeah but what's that oh it's this how
much was that 80 bags
[Laughter]
do what the [ __ ] you want literally do
what the [ __ ] you want that's hilarious
okay guys we're gonna take a very quick
break two to spread the word about our
Partners over at marscape tourism
through today's episode 4 uh so guys
what you don't want to do is wait until
your trouser devils are more disorderly
than Manchester United this season wow
bro bring you below the waist to the top
of the table with manscape let's go come
on come on
use the lawnmower 4.0 to show off your
Modric level ball skills brav and ensure
your member will look good oh my God
Payless come on broth Master you may
have won the cup but your man's but you
but
your mercy will be the champion this
year when you go to myscape.com and
enter the code sng Sierra November golf
for 20 off and free delivery guys thank
you very much let's get back to the
episode
um right you want to talk about The
Little Mermaid yeah so
I have a video right
I got it
so for the audio listeners this is a
blind reaction of The Little Mermaid
trailer that's just been released a few
weeks ago so the mum is obviously
recording the daughter the daughter's
reaction of her seeing the trailer all
right cool uh I just need to find it all
right so lessons all right
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I am
[Music]
with Whitney Houston
[ __ ]
hahaha
that's jokes that is
Yo the first time I saw that video it
flawed me bro that's funny Whitney
Houston that's funny
oh Jesus I've seen so many oh this is a
weird one right so Disney had been like
scrutinized yes a lot for like the
diversity but for being overly diverse
recently just being like they've got
um two chicks lips in in the Buzz
Lightyear movie I love that yeah yeah
and it's like um just like overly
diverse in places where it's not
relevant okay um just like yeah like
they're like for example like having
like a lesbian kiss in the Buzz
Lightyear movie it's like okay cool but
also it's a kids movie why is anyone
else anyway yeah yeah it's a you yeah
it's a you movie Yes universally
Universal movie there shouldn't be any
lipstick yeah why is anyone lips in
anyone like why are you force feeding
diversity in these spaces that don't
need it let it happen naturally
um and that's kind of how I feel about
the aerial thing as well because it's
like it's all really good to be fair I
did see a lot of like Tick Tock like
clips of other ones that one's [ __ ]
funny
black families okay well the kids were
like oh she's black and they're gas and
they're like oh that's cool
um but on the other side I'm also just a
bit like
why are we begging it Ariel's obviously
not black this is It's A Little Mermaid
I can understand who made a different
Mermaid movie and she was black you
cannot make as many black movies as you
want
but obviously I understand it's like a
it's it's obviously a white character
so that's not why are we forcing it I
just don't just I just don't understand
I literally don't understand I mean I
understand but I don't also disagree
cool so tell me your thoughts on it so
it's a case of I should actually I
should probably point out first I don't
give a single [ __ ] yeah facts yeah not
even trigger warning just to clarify any
Disney movie that has any form of
diversity that brings up any form of
Hocus Pocus on the social yeah I don't
care
I do not care I don't give a [ __ ] about
people
Pixar they can [ __ ] about none of them
but nonetheless if we're going to talk
about we'll talk we'll talk about it
yeah yeah premise I don't give it don't
give up whatever I say in the next five
minutes I actually don't give a single
one any DM saying anything else about oh
you but you should watch this and I
don't care I generally don't care same I
don't have a single [ __ ]
um I'm on the fence because I understand
not necessarily understand the pressure
they're getting in terms of like um
these media companies putting out
certain things I.E a black aerial a um
like you said a lesbian kiss in a
[ __ ] Universal movie
is
the kiss is
um what's the word I'm looking for
um the kiss is unnecessary yeah very
very very very very unnecessary because
like you said it's a you movie Universal
movie there shouldn't be lips in Period
um but the reason why I'm on the fence
of
um this aerial thing and some other some
also other like maybe black
um
animated series or moves or whatever
they've got on Netflix or whatever
there's always well not always there's
tends to be like a little backlash but
I'm on the fence because one
I understand that this is an old ass
movie and there's a remake after remake
after remake obviously yes back in the
day the characters were white and all of
this and stuff and blah blah blah
my the reason why I'm on the fence is
because
back in those days
nine times out of ten the people in and
around making the decisions were going
to be white anyway so they're obviously
gonna make characters that suited what
they were trying to depict obviously
it's different like if they made a movie
well like they made Aladdin they made
jungle but all these movies aren't
aren't specifically based in America or
it's meant to be based in like a white
country or white land you know yeah
obviously Little Mermaid Little Mermaid
um
Aladdin is based in like the uh Saudi
Arab in the Arabic world and um what was
the other one I just mentioned just now
The Jungle Book Jungle Books obviously
based in like the India Asia so it's
obviously clear like the characters are
going to be very different but I feel
like the pressure of
the way
um diversity is coming through in
different mediums whether it be
podcasting whether it be uh music videos
whether it be movies whether it be
anything I feel like there is pressure
from people in and around
um those spaces that are pressure
pressurizing the people at the top to
make these decisions yeah so it's like I
understand why they do it I don't
necessarily care that they are or aren't
doing it but they I feel like they also
knew regardless of what they put out
there would be back if they put out
another aerial or another Little Mermaid
let's say scrap this um Chloe what's the
name Chloe Bailey Chloe Hades let's
scrap her let's say the Remake was with
a white lady and she had white um red
hair whatever that looked like the old
one
there would still be backlash like why
is there no because they'll probably
compare it to um
the crab is meant to be like a Jamaican
bread or no yeah do you know what I mean
so if the the crab wasn't Jamaican they
would be they would find something be
like why isn't the crab Jamaican if
Ariel's white do you know what I mean so
it's like
I mean I would never go no one's ever
gonna win I agree so I don't that's why
I don't care yeah I don't care and I
also agree that no one's ever gonna win
but I think the backlash is worse when
you're
forcing diversity rather than just
because when you're when you do I feel
like when you do stuff like that it's so
transparent that you're doing it based
on the pressures of society yeah not
because you actually think there should
be more diversity in the roles do you
know what I mean like if I feel like if
you actually believed there should be
more diversity then we can just start
making more black characters but when we
have a character who is so blatantly
White
and now she's black it to me is just so
transparent like
we're just doing it to shut you the [ __ ]
up and it just like it just seems so
inauthentic to me yeah but it's just
like I don't I genuinely don't if they
made a little moment like I genuinely
don't think there would be that much I
don't think anyone's calling for uh
a black Little Mermaid like I don't
think anyone asked for that like I
people asking for diversity but I don't
think people are asking for a black
Little Mermaid that wasn't specified
yeah so I'm pretty sure if they just
made the movie and she looked exactly
how she did it I don't think anyone
would say anything and if anyone did
pipe up and start saying bro why isn't
she black everyone's like what do you
want about what do you what do you mean
by she's not black in the thing so she's
not gonna be like same way as if they
made a jungle book and Mowgli was white
everyone's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing like there'll be more to it
because it's based in India or another
but same thing like if we change Mowgli
from
Mowgli to white or even Mowgli to Black
they'll be like why are they doing this
like why are you doing this the same
thing with the little mermaid she's
obviously white so just make a white I
saw a comparison where it says oh white
people are going to be mad at this
um so it was obviously like um then
being mad about Arrow being black see
they put Mel Gibson and he's he's the
face of um a buyer pick for Martin
Luther King it says that bill Gibson is
Martin Luther King and it's just him
smiling
it's funny man but I just yeah I had to
say I'm just like first of all yeah
again I feel like I need to reiterate I
don't care I actually do not care yeah
but it's like yeah it's like
why yeah just make some black movies
like you've got the Princess and the
Frog if you want to do a live action
she's obviously going to be black facts
yeah she's making more just make more
black movies
just make more black movies you don't
need to remake old movies just for newer
generations and make them make them
black or make them Asian make them into
like it doesn't I understand it matters
but it doesn't matter yeah we're not
running out of movies yeah just make
more movies with black people in there
and then everyone's happy whereas yeah
if we're just
yeah when I saw she was back I literally
just rolled my eyes I was just like
begging it yeah it's begging it why are
we begging it like this there's plenty
of and there is more stuff it's not it's
not like stuff is not coming through
like there is more stuff coming through
and like all the animated movies that
keep coming out now are super diverse
they're like Asian characters yeah yeah
yeah like turning red for example bear
Asian characters they had the other
Asian one which was on Netflix actually
it's not Disney movie but it's like
called The Wish dragon or something
which is basically Aladdin okay
um but they're all just Asian
um
and yeah you've got like other Disney
movies that come out and like the
diversity seems to be there it's all
good
um but yeah like when I see stuff like
that it's like oh here's an old movie
but we're gonna remake it and just make
the chick black and just like
for why though because like because the
answer should never be because if
someone if you're really talking about
like natural diversity the answer to to
the answer to any question shouldn't be
we're doing this to make it more diverse
because diversity should come naturally
there shouldn't be divert there should
be always diversity of opportunity not
diversity of outcome so like
diversity of if you're if you're
if you're making a remake of someone who
looks like this
when you change what she looks like
you need to I need to believe that the
reason she got the role is that she's so
unbelievably good at playing The Little
Mermaid that it didn't matter what she
looked like which I'm sure that's
probably what their answer is going to
be but it's like is it that tricky role
is it that hard to pretend to be a
mermaid that we had to actually give her
the role because she's so unbelievably
good
um as opposed to all the other [ __ ]
random white girls that I don't know I
don't again I'm getting lost because I
just don't care enough perform a
cognitive argument yeah um but yeah I
just don't I beg it I just think just
make more black just make more black
movies make more diverse movies more
characters everything and it will pop
yeah they don't need to make remix and I
feel like the Remake was to be I don't
care if it's forced or not because I
don't really I'm never going to watch
the movie but
um it just shouldn't have been
like I said was that Whitney Houston
funniest thing I saw that week James the
way she was
looking at this camera oh my god
um this is the skeptic in me this is
also the skeptic in me
um
oh this is this is this is what's wrong
with me I can never sometimes take
things for what they are I always think
like what's going on behind that camera
because that goes like four I was like
how does that four-year-old girl even
know what we really use it is yeah yeah
so and why is she looking at the thing
like this it's like please don't say
that your racist ass mum
made you watch that thing and say oh
when it when at the end of it can you
say this because it'll be funny because
it's a very
very I've not thought about it yeah it's
not her generation yeah
all year old knows what Whitney
he's like
I mean not maybe
you know okay okay the reason why I've
got a counter to that is because one we
don't know what her parents or older
people in a family Listen to For example
when we went to um rem's wedding uh
what's his name Jarrell dravelle the
little his cousin or his nephew yeah
cousin I think it was yeah yeah I think
you were gone by then because you were
ill you had gone to your room but when
everyone was dancing and blah blah my
mom always does the songs that we used
to listen to like 10 15 years ago and
yeah the lyrics oh fair enough yeah is
like how do I think I asked Ram how the
[ __ ] does he know all these bangers how
yeah yeah his parents grew up on all
these stuff so every any details as well
apparently so every time his parents
used to play and listen to these certain
songs he just absorbed them obviously
he's very different well it's not very
different but he is a lot older than
this my girl yeah that girls are usually
you so I understand that there is a bit
of skepticism but I can see how she may
know of Whitney Houston yeah I don't
know it seemed like a very
adult form sentence as well like a very
comedically formed sentence it's not
like how a 40 year old speaks
like in my head this is obviously I'm
just being overly skeptical now like I
feel like a four-year-old like is that
Whitney Houston like while she's singing
she wouldn't dramatically wait for the
whole thing to end and then look to the
camera like was that me or is it me or
is that witty like what four-year-old
speaks like that is that mirrors that
Whitney Houston that's like such a
Zing line do I mean when you put it that
way yeah the timing the delivery all of
it is and she also stuttered at the
beginning of the thing I was like what
what was that just me or is that when he
was just like I'm gonna tell that you
forgot your lines
sounds like you've forgot your lines
all right let's do it anyway move on
let's move on angry about this racist
woman who made his way tick tock
[ __ ] sake [ __ ] you know
um what we got
oh boy Davy day oh so as you know we are
hot on the trail of
um making sure everyone tries patents
their deals from love Island in them
things and we did say mandem don't tend
to get deals and I feel like
because
everyone that comes out of love Island
if you win or if you place like top
three for some reason they always go to
Manny they always go they always go to
money to either live or to go out there
or they get a deal there and it's always
obviously because they're like boohoo
pre-plt Empires owned by one family I
feel like it's easier for them to just
pattern
boohoo slash boohoo man like every guy
every
pop-in guy in in their specific moments
has a clothing line with beautiful man
like rags in the past let's count covert
aside in the past two years I've counted
at least five or six seven probably
different musicians just rotating
rotating yeah that's true bro like props
to them I'm not like they're it's not a
good thing it's not a bad thing it's
just it's just an observational thing
but I'm trying to see man come out of
love Island and bag Hugo Boss
me back Calvin Klein trust me Tommy yeah
yeah it's not the everyday boohoo man
yeah I've got no quantity because I shot
there as well I'm gonna I'm wearing
right now
I just feel like it's so repetitive yeah
it's Rags it's so repetitive there's
there's like the um
they choose their um they choose their
faces like they choose their market like
people accuse them of people critique
boohoo and them kind of things for being
fast fashion yeah but they choose their
influences the same way yeah they don't
choose any staple names they choose hot
people then and there and turn them over
just like they turn over their Trends
facts so their fashion is fast and some
of their faces like they just get
through people quick quick next next
their whole their whole business model
is next
excuse me but Hugo Boss bro
that's what I'm saying they got uh who
they got on there they got a tick tock
Joshua on there they've got feather on
there did I see feather on there am I
making that up I'm not too sure I know
they've got someone on there I know they
got them to you for sure yeah that Tick
Tock Brothers make him money he made the
most money
um from Tick Tock last year I believe
he makes money yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I heard he's making like half a mil a
post yeah I read that as well half a
million dollars a post it's one of them
ones where you hear it and you're like
what the [ __ ] but then you're like well
he is the biggest tick tock in the world
so it's like it makes sense yeah like
what else half a mil a post yeah a post
what am I posted
I could place one thing in jail bro what
we're posting literally that's crazy but
then I always think about I always get
lost in the money of it and then I I
think like but that level of Fame is
crippling it is his name is cabbie by
the way yeah I feel like because cabbies
act or like what he does on Tick Tock is
so
it's monotonous like he does one thing
yeah he literally does
like can can is that yes he's making
millions
but I would be I'd be so brain dead yeah
I mean it's one of them things was like
he he definitely he's lucky that he
definitely has a time a short time like
lifetime in the thing he's not going to
be in five years people instead of gonna
be watching his like non-speaking thing
he's got probably like another year or
two in him I don't think he's got that
long because he was doing it for time
before he even was it true it's true he
was doing it all locked down all of
these things so I don't think it's about
that long the f is saving because if
he's doing 400k posts now
let's say he's doing 400k a post now
he's doing that for the next year we're
talking like let's say he bags four mil
over the next year then the year after
that it dies down he's get maybe doing
100K a post he can still bag another
Mill These Times he's still got the Hugo
Boss deal he still could be doing other
[ __ ] yeah so as long as he collates a
healthy 10 mil over the next couple
years yeah to just Nest acting he's fine
he doesn't have to do anything ever
again true so even though the lifetime
is short the money's so big that it
balances out yeah I hope he um I hope he
still gets like
um collabs and stuff with like Hugo Boss
and all these all these stuff that was a
big big boy people will gas for him when
he did that collab that's a big boy
calendar he did something with Snoop
Dogg as well not too long ago yeah they
need to shout me Hugo
oh yeah
oh yeah
why are you saying that I don't know I
reckon I could do something for them
there's a little thumb yeah just a
little long like a little long leg Yeah
I could I could help them with something
man let's just chat yeah that's that's
Hugo let's just have lunch Hugo yeah
yeah did you know fun fact this is
probably burnt every bridge
um that I'm about to try and build okay
did you know Hugo Boss were literally
the the like uh principal designer for
like the Nazis uniforms no I did not
yeah there's actually quite a few
um like famous
uh like designers that are designed for
not designed for Nazis yeah but in terms
of like the the actual Nazi uniform I
heard it was like Hugo Boss with the big
boys in there
really yeah yeah plot twist really yeah
I'd still hold it back from them but
obviously racist
wow yeah yeah
as well say again I won't be surprised
if Tommy hilfiger's there as well how
old is Tommy Tommy is it it's not even
old enough is it um Tommy Hilfiger is it
odd enough to be in there
let's see
I think Gucci's in there really yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure
really yeah let me Google it I'll show
you oh mad oh no he's he's well I say
he's only 71. but um so famous designers
for
Nazi uniform
yeah Hugo Boss
Hugo Boss was an active member of the
Nazi party
wow yes sir keep going I'm intrigued now
five big name fashion designers
uh who are ties to the Nazis
uh uh Coco Chanel
Balenciaga
Louis Vuitton Louis Vuitton
's your these are all French [ __ ]
Hugo Boss Hugo Boss is actually German
so yeah
bro
really yeah bro
wow mad wow mad yeah that's mad bro I'm
telling you that's mad
I'm telling you
hey man what goes around comes around
bro I don't even know what to say all I
need to all I want to know is that they
need to patent me something
I'll put it all behind me
I'll put it all behind for that for the
right bag
to the right back to have me in them
orange and black yeah
that was some sleep yeah yeah give me
that sort of neck with a tan jacket
without fur inside I can do that
can do that I don't know why they're
making it I can't do that I can't see
you hold up a model pose James I can't
see it I can't see it bro I'll be there
this thing yeah I'll be there I just I
just don't feel like you'll take the
instructions well oh what
they'd be like okay this no no this and
just take the picture running
stop doing all this
AJ comes and goes like this one time and
it's this what's why you might giving me
bear instructions you're a newbie yeah
I'm not even playing
things will laugh I'm not playing and
everyone knows the fact that so would
everyone I know it's just funny it's
just funny to hear right have we got
energy questions
no no we've got 80 questions
um
so the question this week guys sorry my
throat has been so hoarse today
sorry guys
um
question of the week is what's the worst
thing you did as a kid as you already
know I already bet these ones were
gnarly
gnarly you know [ __ ] I wasn't expecting
you to say that gnarly I'll be
skateboarders wow anyway
you understand how to explore my
vocabulary in my brain explore the words
I want to use I'll let you say whatever
the [ __ ] you want it's just through me
that said are we skateboarding
I feel like I'm wearing [ __ ]
Quicksilver it's always that was the
brand in it Quicksilver silver man said
gnarly kick flips and a [ __ ] keychain
sharper read the question literally shut
the [ __ ] up and read the question
[ __ ] hell brav I always say it again
Point proven in it [ __ ] read your
thing you fast fashion yeah
right what's the worst thing you did as
a kid
I dipped my willy into a glass of water
for an art who was rude to me and asked
if she liked it
Willy you know you knew he was a union
willy willy wow I hate that word I
[ __ ] hate that word really
made another kid choke on a toy on
purpose Jesus Christ asked my parents
what anal sex was whilst we were eating
dinner
Cutlery would have no bro no dad that's
anal sex
that that I'll be like that home dad
from before it stops now
it stopped right now
my brother beat up the pastor's Kid Rock
Matt fed my brother's pet fish my snot
on a daily basis it lived for three
years what
suck
I was such an attention [ __ ] I lied
about knowing someone on 9 11 when it
happened
bro bro I bet bear you swallow that
fight I remember I was a kid I used to
say uh Tim Duncan was my uncle
Rags I can't even smoke I was I wanted
to ask you that as a question time ago
and I was like by the way before I ask
you this question do you mind if people
know your surname and then that's how we
got into it yeah I remember yeah yeah
yeah bro Rags yeah I used to say Tim
Duncan was my uncle all the time I was a
little attention home myself that's
hilarious
um I used to steal I used to still
change out my dad's girlfriend's purse
and replace it with pennies
facts I'll do that too right isotel two
pounds from my mum every day
yep ice is still two pounds from my mum
um for lunch because this is everything
so if I'm every day this is what I used
to do right so I I think I don't know if
I told you I think I've said it on here
before I don't know if she knows it or
not but it doesn't matter anymore
um I used to still too proud of her
purse because she told me
when I first started high school she was
like you got two pan a day for lunch as
I bet then about three days into my
first week I would say mum can I take
two pan out of your purse and she'd be
like big man why are you taking two
pound every day and I was like whoa you
said two pound a day for lunch she was
like yeah bit brother you don't have to
spend the whole two pound every day I'm
like two pounds
we can't speak because your mum will
beat you up and you're like
okay
expensive sweet sauce nowadays a
flapjack is 130. I've got 70p for a
juice literally what the [ __ ] I need
more than two band everyone else gets a
five facts everyone else she's expecting
me to stop powders too bad I was like
right sorry and she was like take the
two pound two pounds I used to take two
cigarettes as well
that's at the two pound and then I'll
take two [ __ ] cigarettes why I'd sell
them 50p a pop
that two tons of three
every day I used to take two cigarettes
and my two pounds oh I shot them 50p
your boy's got three pound now then the
two cigarettes turned to three because
the market yeah
it was up
jokes yeah
I don't even know a favor yeah no no no
she would just buy more because she'll
smoke less if there's less cigarettes
and your boy's making a bit of a he's
wetting his beat yeah in the playground
yeah I'm hustling but yeah two pound and
two cigarettes a day hustling I thought
this was power yeah mum was doing up
power in the playground that's hilarious
gas I remember hilarious anyway back to
it what's the worst thing you did as a
kid my Grandma had Alzheimer's and
forgot who I was so I told her I didn't
know who she was either she started
screaming like crazy I know no
no
fam can you imagine some old lady she's
like who are you I'm I said who are you
on a joke thing she'll screw hell she
will drop her bags
shut the [ __ ] up shut up
nah bro like Nan I'm sorry I'm so sorry
it's mean to me so she'll scream
I'll try to hold it hold it wrist after
stop stop stop non-stop none stop stop
stop stop stop stop you gotta cause the
Ruckus now stop I was only joking stop
I'm your grandson Professor Jesus Christ
that's funny who are you who are you
drop everything
I used to like playing with lighters and
one night he got a little out of control
and I set my bedroom on fire oh Christ I
used to cut my sister's hair off in her
sleep if she pissed me off I kept it all
in a jar
what the [ __ ]
fam played dead for a babysitter even
held my breath during the 911
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my breath
no bruh that's so funny that's so funny
what would you actually do but I
wouldn't know what what to do held your
breath and
breathing and I'm just
coffee
now bro I was scream and cry I'm I've
just left you so you're the babysitter
I've left with my missus ah take care of
my younger for me we'll be out we'll be
back by 11.
there's food in the fridge there's
everything we get dip you go you've not
seen me yet I'm upstairs chilling you
guys are doing a little thing downstairs
sorry you've not seen the kid yet I've
got yeah yeah I've got my misses you
know go upstairs
let's call him
Joseph
you say Joseph Joseph I'm taking care of
you today blah blah come down come down
come down we've got some fish fingers in
the oven for you it's gonna be nice and
hard you know barbecue sauce ketchup
means
come on man I've got a PlayStation cell
what are we doing what are we saying
love is blind starts in 15. hurry up I
love his blind you hear nothing
Joseph
you hear nothing all right
are we playing games playing games you
want some Tickle Monster thing all right
all right coming upstairs if I come
upstairs it's gonna be beef
start going upstairs start going
upstairs
you knock on the door no answer Joseph
no answer
you just you see Joseph on the better
pale just pale
legs what's the word I'm contorted legs
contorted Trail tongue out I said who's
been in here
I'll check the windows first before I
check the parts I'm checking the windows
because I'm thinking I'm next yeah
oh
I've met who's been in it why is he
drapes like this he left him like that
because you don't just naturally lie
like this Joseph
I don't know I can imagine I'll just
like clicking
wake up
bro would you like would you touch him
would you like poke him or something
I don't know I probably think I think
it's a play play tank a little bit
Jersey and I'll do that on his lips
or just hold his nose yeah hold his
[ __ ] noses
bro that's the thing I'm here I don't
think they could finesse me yeah because
I'm he's waking up he's waking up I'll
hold his [ __ ] nose where the [ __ ] up
I remember when I had a did I tell you I
used to have a babysitter called Amy she
used to torture me and my brother oh
isn't it I remember she used to torture
us she used to pinch the back of our
legs for fun
she was a [ __ ] she
used to pinch the back of our legs for
fun we would scream go away we would
scream
scream and cry that's abuse of power oh
it was my mom smacked you on her face oh
is it yeah
I was thinking what she used to run
Chase around her house or pinch the back
of my legs it was so painful I can't
tell you how painful she just did it for
fun yeah because we used a customer
because she was a fat [ __ ]
she used to pissed me off as she stuck
so she used to come up and they are
trying to [ __ ] and she's just she's just
a moody teenager yeah and I remember we
were like seven or eight and then she
was just bare Moody bro so me and my
brother used to just cuss her that's my
shot man you're fat anyway and then
she's about what and then just taste as
a pinch a bag of legs
and you're laughing but you're not
laughing
[Music]
everywhere yeah and then she'll guess I
remember we had to use these kitchen
stools okay I used to hide under the
stool like Amy stop stop stop stop stop
and she will get you and she'll [ __ ]
pinch and twist once she got you yeah
she'll get you and then she'll pinch it
yank it off and then go again you'll be
screaming fuhad oh my God screaming and
then when she's done with you you'll be
crying about you're a [ __ ] prick
[ __ ] you Amy it's about what and you're
like it's not I need to just run
upstairs and she'll do it again so I
told my mom my mom was I swear
went to my yard because she lived on our
street went down there not on the door
spoke to my shoes I just need to speak
to Amy real quick she was like yeah yeah
yeah Amy come down she was like oh the
boys told me that he was like pinching
him and hurting him she was like yeah
don't [ __ ] touch myself again sick
because he don't [ __ ] yeah you stupid
[ __ ]
wow that's just hated Amy I [ __ ] hate
it I can tell you but you've never told
that story before that's enough all
right
um yeah back to worst things you've done
as a kid spoon fed my cousin baby oil
wow bro
that's dangerous
spoon bit my cousin baby oil
what
nah bro dangerous mind them don't care
[ __ ] chops The Ting ran away fell over I
haven't recovered since
that's like punish my dad for being mean
by only putting hot water in his bath
and waited for the scream
nah bro pulled my sister's wig off in a
fight in front of the whole family
unplug the DJ's equipment at a party
because I wanted to go home no
no
no
oh
yeah
my mum would have murder me I can't even
imagine because I wanted to go home the
whole thing's getting locked off
kids are crazy they have balls of steel
yeah actually yeah once they felt all
the licks there is to be felt they've
got to do what they want yeah they're
Immortal after that yeah they're
literally Immortal after that stole my
mom's bracelet to give it to a girl in
school only to be friend zoned oh bro
imagine
only to be free I've bought jewelry give
me give it back
I've just giving you jewelry babes yeah
twins it's a friend zone
I'm yanking a necklace you know how to
yank it off together yeah oh drapes it
what um what movie is that um what's
that skateboarding moving like ATL ATL
I'm sure TI did it Yanks it off um
what's her face
yeah yeah
um dumped glue on a golf skirt in my
class because she was annoying and
pretty at the same time
is it by accident her name is Lauren
I've never felt fear like this in my
life tell me the story bro bro we were
in textiles class I was bored I was
[ __ ] bored yeah
and now you start to flirt with this
chick
because she was the new guy in class she
wasn't even that paying but she was just
new me unknown territory yeah yeah so I
was like Laura what is it winding her up
yeah and I got a scissors and I used to
be like Pat next to her ear I was like
and she was like [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ]
off and I was like yeah and I went to do
it next to it here and as I went to do
it she turned her head her ponytail fell
straight in between these scissors bro
snip how much fell off all of it
hahaha
all of it
all of it all of it fell off
no and I was like oh my God right I'm
screaming in the glass I did it I was
like oh my God and she was like stop
being an idiot she didn't believe it and
then as a boy Marcus that sat next to me
and he was like Jesus Christ and then
she was like now and he was like he
[ __ ] cut your ponytail off and she
was like shut up you man are boring me
I'm tired of this bully yeah his wind-up
thing is boring your little boys you men
are both little boys take your scissors
and [ __ ] off fam I said Lauren Lauren I
I swear to God I'm [ __ ] sorry it was
an accident the teacher her name was Mrs
Rowe yeah she was humongously obese and
she had glasses and she was annoying
yeah she stormed over she was like what
scar nice yeah
I said Miss I'll swear down Miss I swear
down I was joking around with scissors
and she was like first of all facts
first of all
first of all Mr Duncan what do you mean
joking around with scissors
are you [ __ ] serious I was like Miss
you're missing the place I'm missing a
hole wait I was playing with the
scissors
I was playing with the scissors on a
joke joke thing I know what I'm doing
yeah I'm not gonna hurt anyone
but
she wasn't listening and she turned her
head into the scissors literally not my
fault that Ting snitched and I don't
know where it's safe they sent me to the
what the exclusion room whatever it's
called yeah yeah they sent me in there
to sit in silence with all the
degenerate use
they sat me in there all afternoon oh my
God I was livid and my mom had to come
in on Monday to to allow me to go back
to class but if your mom doesn't go in
they sent you in there it's like the
choki in [ __ ] Matilda they just sit
you in there until your mom's willing to
come in and sort you out and it was one
of those things where I realized I
haven't got a leg to stand on yeah
because as soon as I tell it a story
everyone's like what I'm playing this
why are you playing with scissors my guy
you're supposed to be learning this is
what I'm sending you here for I promise
you now James my parents would have come
to school that day and slapped me in
front of everybody
everybody oh it was terrifying man said
all of it he found the whole thing fell
what did she say bro oh she went [ __ ]
crazy and started crying
and all the girls were staring daggers
at me and obviously your boy got
defensive yeah and I was like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] shut up there's a [ __ ]
accident piss off it was nice and I just
got so hot and prickly I got so hot bro
I was just like oh I want to die I
literally want to die because now I'm
the villain
for no reason
I was living bro livid I didn't know
what to do and then she had to obviously
get a haircut yeah and she had some Bob
saying here and it looked Butters
because she had a round face as it was
so when she had this Bob thing I just
saw oh she's lost all sex appeal and
I've I did that to her I [ __ ] did
that to her and I remember she clapped
back she clapped back because
back because there was a girl how you
remember these backing stories is beyond
me years later she clapped back when I
was 17. I just started chirpsing my
soon-to-be girlfriend
and then she worked she Lauren used to
work in New Look and the girl who I was
chips in the works in new look as well
hit
she Lauren hurt
that this girl was talking to me so
without saying oh you're talking to
James she was like talking about college
and all this stuff that six one was a
six one last time and she was like oh
yeah yeah yeah there's this really
annoying guy
in my class in sixth form really
annoying his name's James she her
description of me was he's black and
he's got a massive nose
the girl was like swear
I know
his black he's got massive nose she was
like swear and she came back and told me
about it the girl came back and told me
about it she was like ah I swear this
guy was talking about you at work the
other day and I was like
oh it's not it's not yeah
I swear
Lauren I swear yes she was like she just
told you annoying she said she her
description of you was black with a big
nose and I was like this [ __ ] [ __ ]
this [ __ ] luckily I had that I was like
she just hates me because she fancies me
obviously she fancies me I turned her
down and when we're in year eight I'd
Snips off and she was like oh sorry okay
it makes sense I'm not speaking Jesus
makes that's Jesus Christ that was a
disaster Miss I was just playing with
scissors I'm telling you now miss robe
was like big man if you say another word
you're going to jail yeah my guy
I was playing with scissors I wanted to
be like well we're in Texas I was like
bro it's not it's yeah what else am I
gonna do but play with scissors you
might go out it's sewing machines
everywhere this is so boring
oh that was a funny story James all
right sorry guys it's so good it's all
good I've only got a few left all right
bet
I told my teenage I told my teenage
sister's friends that I caught her
Snogging the mirror
my friend's mum was my friend's mom was
hot when I slept over I made sure I'd
licked her bras in her closet disgusting
what disgusting
dipped wheat biscuits in my Celiac
teacher's drink at school she was gone
for six months
Farm that's playing with someone's life
literally did I ever talk about the
French teacher got bullied out my school
your school stories give me life my name
is Miss Kappa machio it's just a French
teacher I feel like four foot nothing I
think it rings a bow because I feel like
after you said it
um I mentioned about one of my English
teachers I got yeah yeah yeah she came
to school with a black guy what are you
there as well yeah yeah yeah yeah who
put pause on you because you're out yeah
this is yeah if we didn't time you up
then no one guesses
you have to get the Whiteboard lower and
it just set up
the worst entry because she didn't start
in the school okay so when she came into
school everyone that she was teaching
had already been there for a couple
years so no one knew her as like an OG
teacher yeah but when there's a new
teacher they get rinsed she got rid Miss
capomaccio yeah and I found out later
that she only came to our school because
she got bullied out of Alaska which was
my step-sister's school in Luton because
I was running joke on a Saturday
afternoon yeah talk about I just want
French teacher she's bare sure she
actually looked like Hezbollah
bro she literally looked at the female
version of Hezbollah and as dread
because all these are bullioner and she
was like swears her name is Kappa machio
I was I burst out laughing she was like
yeah she could run out of our school as
well
oh [ __ ] man Bros being a teacher is
actually the hardest job in the world
what was she teaching French
they used to leave England yeah she's
actually yeah she was literally French
as well yeah yeah
that's hilarious oh it was it was harsh
man I got three more I get went too far
on my mum while she was asleep I shot
myself instead yuck found two enormous
vibrators in the bathroom I live alone
with my dad
laughs
that's funny that's funny
bro that that's like a comedic script
wow that's a well-played joke
Jesus funny
Jesus
I gave my mom the address of the lady's
house my dad kept on visiting no you
didn't
no
you did not that is it's like a coup in
the yard it's like Civil War I could
never find out why you did that to me
because obviously yes I'm the village
but how dare you you're my child bro
what we side are you on clearly not mine
literally you are my you bro I made you
you're my dude to me how can you do this
to me bro
[ __ ] gave her the address how did you
even know the address [ __ ] nose Bro [ __ ]
nose [ __ ] it but yeah that was the um
that was the question of the week guys
oh God you liked it all right guys thank
you very very much for today this was
fun
um as always guys head on over to
patreon.com shits and gigs to uh catch
us every single Thursday speaking of
Thursday guys if we're gonna see you at
Shepherd's Bush Empire this Thursday
it's going to be a Vibe yeah man we're
gonna have some fun and literally cannot
wait guys so as always level of love
[Music]
good